edie Boosh added the Pittsburgh
post-gazette Steelers beat writer and
Edie joins us now of course we have news
with Le'Veon Bell he's coming back in a
month
so everybody's rejoicing I'm assuming is
that right ed huh there's so much mixed
emotion here and that's assuming we
believe he's coming back in a month Dan
because he's made all kinds of
statements before that he was gonna
start the season and he was gonna hold
out the whole season that he was gonna
have his best season and so this is the
latest this sounds more reasonable he
sounds committed from what I read of him
talking to Jeremy Fowler and so it
sounds like he's coming back yes so what
the week of the bye for them okay why do
you think he's coming back now or in a
month I don't know you know if it's just
we thought he was going to come in and
they did two before the start of the
season he didn't do that so the longer
he stayed out of this quote-unquote save
himself from all his the carries and
everything he was gonna get I figured
he's just well why not just stay out the
whole season because he would still be a
free agent next year why lose all this
money up till now why now now the only
thing I can think of Dan is last year he
came in Monday before the first game and
they used him right away he could use
the bye week and the next week that
would give him two weeks of practice
before the first game that's the only
thing I can think of why he's coming in
that if you're the Steelers how do you
think they'll use him you know is this
Batman around with a bunch of guys I
think they would get the two week roster
exemptions first of all and practice in
that first week see how he's doing and
then the second week determine if he's
ready to play or not if he's ready yeah
you just used you know he just lifts
that roster exemption and use it now
they they could do the two weeks thing
and not pay him for those two weeks as
well and my guess is why would you pay
him for the bye week when there's no
game if he's just practicing so he could
lose that week of pay too but the pay at
this point doesn't seem to be the big
sticking point
how is that Ravens lost playing locally
not well they went from beating camp on
Monday night to and and there being some
optimism around town - now this team is
not going to even make the playoffs or
maybe not even have a winning season
that's that's we have a we have a saying
here win Super Bowl lose no Super Bowl
that's week to week so it's it's very
pessimistic here this week because of
holly's walked on defense specifically
and you know that their schedule they
have a brutal schedule they've lost both
of their games at home so far yeah just
trying to figure this out and even when
I saw the news with lady on bail coming
back I still wondered what's what's the
likelihood of a trade before he even
comes back what do you think that is
well you know in baseball they they do
trade for rent players then we've seen
that all the time and that's what bail
would be because they can't give them a
good contract this year they'd have to
wait until after the season so because a
team want to give is their team out
there that has a cap room it feels it's
a running back away from you know making
a run at the playoffs and it's you know
well the report said second round and a
player I am I think they'd take a third
rounder I really do because they're not
gonna get a third round comp pick if he
leaves as a free agent till 2020 and
would be at the end of the round if
somebody's willing to give a third round
it would be next year it would be you
know higher but we'll see III mean there
might be a team out there willing to
give up a third runner but then with the
Steelers it depends where they are -
they lose these next two games and he
comes back there one for one or what are
you playing for you got Jets Colts
Browns Eagles have been mentioned would
the steelers trade him to the Patriots
of the Patriots we're interested in it I
could see an NFC team like the Eagles
and they've had a good
[ __ ] with that club too so I just I
could see that one eye they're not gonna
trade him to the Browns or in a division
they got to play them again
I just you know Colts maybe yeah I
thought the Niners if Garoppolo was
still healthy that they they might have
done it with McRaven getting hurt and in
the Colts as a possibility as well but
yeah I'm wondering what these offensive
linemen are gonna think when all of a
sudden hey I'm back guys everything
everything's good
how do you think his teammates are gonna
react when they see him walk in the door
I think if he if they feel he can help
they can he can help them win they'll
just go ahead they're not gonna be going
out to you know Dave & Buster's every
night or to dinner but I think they
certainly it would be blocking for him
and you know that's the way of life but
I think they could get together and it
wouldn't be a problem
good luck have fun no this week head
around in the coming weeks and we'll
talk to you soon I'm sure
well lady I'm bail for guys like me is
that even though he hasn't come in here
is the gift that keeps on giving
yeah I agree Thank You ed all right that
said bhushan Pittsburgh post-gazette for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you